morning everybody seven o'clock in the
UK 10 o'clock here in southern turkey
it's now been two days since this region
was devastated by two major earthquakes
and time is running out to find
survivors of a disaster which has
already claimed close to 9 000 miles
we'll bring you the very latest this
morning from this tent city where we are
this morning more than a thousand people
are now living here some of them
surrounding us this morning and from our
correspondence covering the story from
the epicenter plus we'll ask the new
conservative party chairman Greg hands
what the British government is doing to
help it is Wednesday the 8th of February
the desperate search for survivors in a
Race Against Time nearly 8 000 people
and are known to have died in two
massive earthquakes in turkey and also
in Syria
this is a scene elsewhere in offer this
morning as a huge rescue effort
continues in freezing temperatures to
try to Free People trapped under Rubble
hope amidst the despair the miracle
Rescue of a newborn baby found in the
wreckage
foreign
shouts of joy as a family is pulled from
the ruins after a day of searching
search teams and international Aid
arrive in Turkey but the war and
sanctions make it difficult for help to
get to Syria
[Music]
morning from a city in Ruins after one
of the worst natural disasters in recent
history it's now more than two days
since two earthquakes caused such
Devastation here in turkey and in Navy
and neighboring Syria as well a huge
Rescue Mission has again continued
through the night in a Race Against Time
to try to find survivors trapped under
the rubble tens of thousands of people
across the region have been left
homeless forced to camp out in freezing
conditions like this
so let me tell you a little bit about
what we know so far since this time
yesterday almost 9 000 people are now
known to have died with that number
expected to rise yeah
the Turkish government says more than 31
000 people have been injured again the
real figure is likely to be much higher
some of those have been airlifted to
hospitals in Istanbul and also the
capital Ankara
and the UN say they are exploring all
avenues to get supplies to Northwestern
Syria after releasing more than 20
million pounds from its emergency fund
to help kick-start the humanitarian
response let's remind you of what
happened here just a little over two
days ago the first 7.8 magnitude
earthquake hit Southern turkey just
after 4 15 a.m local time on Monday
morning around nine hours later a
magnitude 7.5 earthquake struck a
neighboring Province it was just one of
hundreds of aftershocks felt across
Southern turkey and Northern Syria I
mean urfa one of the city's hardest hit
by this disaster
yeah
I want to show you around this tented
City it was hastily set up by the aid
agency here in turkey and we were spoken
to a lot of the people in the native
tongue and they have agreed to allow us
to walk through what is their community
at least for now Nathan will show you
some of the tents that have been set up
these young people walking with us a
little bit of Joy I think for them it's
certainly a little bit of Interest
um given what they've had to endure over
the last few days just watch these 10
pegs Nathan as you come through
this gives you an idea of the number of
tents that are here is actually in the
um you see at the car park of the museum
here it's an architectural Museum also
damaged during the earthquake but not as
bad as some of the other buildings we
have seen just watch these youngsters
just be careful as we come past Thank
You Salon
and just to show you here this is ice
and snow it gives you an idea of just
how cold it's been over the last few
days now uh this is a mahmoud's tent
Mahmoud is from Syria he has 25 people
from his family living in this small
tent when they saw what happened they
decided to immediately flee the home
scene is with me and Daley's going to
interpret for us uh mahmoud's Story
how did it get here foreign
25 of us for several days outside under
the rain under the freezing conditions
and finally we managed to to reach here
as we speak to him is it okay if Nathan
goes inside to sue
foreign
we're very thankful for the authorities
Who provided us with some Aid who had
soup for example for breakfast and for
lunch but look we have no electricity we
have no heating we're very cold the
situation is very difficulties
can you expect the 25 people in there
tell them oh she's Clinging On Tight
there um how long do they expect to be
here for
um
she's not being able to sleep at night
she's crying all the time because of the
cold it's so cold the situation is very
tough it's very hard yeah how long do
they expect to be here come here
we still don't know until the until the
authority saw the government tells us to
leave we don't know why did they come
here what made them think immediately to
come here
we were sleeping in the garden but we
heard that they were setting off a 10th
10th you know
we came here when we heard that people
were coming here for help and for for
shelter we came here what were the
conditions like at home
foreign
the aftershocks and the Tremors stopped
and then they managed to get the family
to him okay and finally we've had
several Tremors already this morning how
are they every time that happens how do
they feel um
so yeah yesterday at 10 o'clock and at
three o'clock we felt the Tremors and we
were scared
I have five young children myself and I
have all dressed
sleeping on this Fair floor with
sub-zero temperatures
this way we are going to be uh spending
our morning here at this refugee camp
um and I'll show you around a little bit
more later on but for now it's Siobhan
standing by at yorkston for a Sivan good
morning
okay we've just lost Siobhan just for
now so so let's go to uh dazian tap and
Ezra is there for us um Austra what's it
like where you are yes sir
just complete Devastation Ka people here
are losing hope very quickly as the 48
window has passed for immediate help to
be the most successful people are
standing around they're very frustrated
with search efforts they've told diggers
that they would rather go in themselves
and dig with their bare hands they're
saying I'm not doing it right and now
they're asking for people to be silent
as they call to see if victims inside
could hear them and this gazian tap is
an area that's synonymous with welcoming
refugees from Syria it's close to the
border and millions of syrians have come
in here and so this Gathering now is
Turkish families there are Syrian
families here waiting to hear if their
loved ones can be retrieved from the
rubble and it's it's just devastating it
really is people seem to be in shock
unable to speak and just waiting waiting
as patiently as they can just across the
border
there's there's very little that we can
confirm on how much is how much damage
has been caused in Syria Pathways into
into rebel-held areas of Syria have been
severely damaged the UN says that the
Babel HOA border that we know to have
actually allowed for Aid to enter Rebel
Health areas has been damaged by the
earthquake so as you said they're
exploring all avenues and the white
helmets that we've known in the past to
be very experienced in terms of
retrieving bodies during the war from
airstrikes from Syrian and Russian
forces are saying that they are unable
to answer so many calls for help they've
answered 30 calls so far to 30 different
locations they're getting calls from
more than 700 locations okay so so as
we've seen here in Turkey the
devastation is still we still can't
grasp the scale of it it's very much
that case the case in Syria but as as we
said that there's very little to
actually be able to confirm as access
becomes more and more difficult
okay for now thank you still trying to
establish a link with Siobhan for now
but she did send us a report about
what's been happening over the last two
days we've seen some pretty dramatic
rescues if you were with us on the
breakfast show yesterday morning you
would have seen uh exactly what was
happening just about 10 minutes away
from we are as they dug beneath the
rubble to try to find 35 people who were
still trapped by Nightfall and into the
midnight and early hours still no sign
of Life there in Syria residents found a
crying newborn baby still connected by
its umbilical cord to her mummy and a
warning that we're about to show you
images of the infant pulled from the
rubble here Siobhan's report
among the desperation the extraordinary
a baby girl born under the rubble in
Northwest Syria
hearing her cries Rescuers cut the
umbilical cord from her mother's body
she is the only member of her family to
survive the quake
this is a moment of Hope in a Time
overshadowed by Death
bodies are discovered after digging with
bare hands of basic tools
the white helmets continue to work
through the 90s Syria with little
International help
aid agencies face difficulties reaching
Northern Syria as they negotiate away
across the only border crossing
the situation is really really tough we
are feeling pain and we have been
appealing for Aid since the first hours
of this earthquake
to be honest when we reach a person who
died some 15 minutes or half an hour ago
we really blame ourselves saying if we
had exerted more effort or if we had had
more equipment at our disposal we would
have pulled out this person alive from
under the rubble
in the 10 Turkish provinces worst hit by
the earthquakes Rescuers are still
searching the ruins of collapsed
buildings
crews are working against the clock the
72-hour window critical for survival is
closing
the occasional discovery of a survivor
in the wreckage brings much needed hope
for many here
the threat is now the freezing
temperatures and limited shelter while
they face A desperate weight for help
Siobhan Robbins Sky News turkey
still try to establish those
Communications with Siobhan we'll be
with her as soon as we can as you can
imagine working within an earthquake
zone it's very difficult to communicate
with some of our colleagues sometimes
these are some let's just have another
walk while we are waiting or just
squeezing by excuse me I'm sorry I'm
sorry we've seen a lot of youngsters
playing outside this Tent today actually
this morning and they were having a how
can youngsters find the energy to play
when they're in such dire circumstances
but perhaps not completely aware of the
challenges that they're facing look at
this little one I saw her eating some
soup with a bread roll a little bit
early on afad is the agency say I was
telling you here hello how are you Salam
and just wander over to this tent here
um my jokes are not with me just at the
moment watch your step so I know that
he's heading off to find other people
for us to to talk to as I said this is
the car park normally of the
there we go there we go the museum
behind us the architectural Museum are
here normally where locals would come
and wander around to look at some of the
artifacts there instead it's been made
into this makeshift City this makeshift
turns something like 1500 people are
living here 25 people per tent and when
we were speaking to Mahmoud uh just a
short time ago he said he and his family
dropped everything fled from Syria
they've pitched up here they've no idea
how long they are likely to be here it's
a situation that is being replicated
right around this country and we soon
presume also into Syria as well let's
bring you Alex Crawford's latest report
they're using bits of rubble
whatever they can get their hands on to
reach those buried
[Music]
can anyone hear me she's shouting
they can hear sounds
so they keep calling
and listening for the loved ones who
lived here
[Music]
but they've come with little more than
courage and a great deal of Hope
and their tools make barely any impact
on an eight-story building now all on
the ground floor
relatives look on sick with worry
and a bubbling anger growing inside
[Music]
I have no support yet from the
government
we have now 40 hours no one cup yeah
nobody nobody are you here to touch this
I understand from the 40 hour I am the
one waiting here from 40 hours no one
car is game an area here the time now we
are dying here no it's dying okay just
dying
they stand in huddles weeping and find
Comfort by talking to the trapped
children they may never see again
on yard
be strong then he is she's saying to him
be strong we are here
the fury is real and raw the
government's not here she's shouting
enough enough
this city which hugs the Syrian border
appears to be one of the worst hit it's
home to a huge number of Syrian refugees
who fled the war to safety here and the
hatai mayor is from the main opposition
party stoking suspicions that this may
have contributed to the little Aid
evident here
we saw residents helping themselves to
food and supplies from a supermarket
which had been broken into but also saw
a television being carted away
it's because we're hungry one man told
us
desperation is haunting this city
for the love of God please help us she
begs us God I'm waiting for help she
says her husband's trapped upstairs in
their flat and has poor sight please I
expect help from my government
for so many people who feel they're not
getting the help that they need
it
not one person he tells us we haven't
seen a single soul here
we don't even have any water to drink or
even have any bread to eat she goes on
my daughter's in there with her two kids
another man tells us they've died in
that house
there are moments of sheer Joy a young
baby is pulled out
after so many hours she is a real living
miracle
she's too young to remember what
happened but her family will remind her
she's one who beat the odds on turkey's
terrible day of earthquakes
the baby's mother has somehow kept her
alive and she too has been found they're
both badly dehydrated and the young mum
looks traumatized
this has been a terrifying experience
for them all
there are questions about how well
prepared they were here for a disaster
long predicted to happen but every time
someone is coaxed to safety and guided
down the piles of broken concrete which
were once their homes it inspires The
Rescuers to keep on going
but there are far more suffering far too
many mothers consumed by grief as the
wafer than hoped they were clinging onto
finally disappears
The Rescuers don't give up though there
are frantic efforts to try to
resuscitate her boy they try and they
keep on trying
this is a young life they cannot save
this region is probably uniquely
ill-equate to cope with a natural
disaster of this scale and the heartache
and grief is going to grow over the next
few days and weeks Alex Crawford Sky
News and antacia Southern turkey
chairman new chairman of the
conservative party hello to you Mr hands
thank you for joining us good morning
congratulations on your new position
what you're going to do to help these
people surrounding me this morning
well look we already have on our way um
um Aid First Responders for
um search dogs these have been directly
at the request of the Turkish government
obviously I've just seen your report and
the horrific scenes and our hearts go
out to everybody who's been affected by
as you rightly point out okay this uh in
terms of this earthquake happening at
such a
um such a challenged part of the world
uh Syria the Turkish border I mean it's
a really terrible uh situation and in
many ways a terrible place for this to
actually happen but we are responding
we'll respond to any further requests
from the Turkish government in
particular to provide assistance from
the UK
uh what was the delay in sending the aid
we've sent the aid as soon as we can in
direct response to the Turkish
government request uh it's on its way at
the moment I think it may be about to
arrive this morning
yeah I think it arrived actually about
one o'clock yesterday but it was delayed
it should have arrived the day before
minutes matter in circumstances like
this do you know why it was delayed
I don't have though the facts of the uh
the length of time uh but we all I know
is that we have responded directly to
that request from the Turkish government
We Stand ready to provide more
assistance should further requests come
through
are we sending uh anything else
are we sending any help we've sent as I
said 76 people Four Dogs We Stand ready
are we sending anything else are we
sending anything else as I said we're
we're going to respond to uh requests
from the authorities uh from the Turkish
government uh we stand ready to do so as
soon as we get those requests coming in
what about financial aid
well we already provide of course a lot
to the regional one of the biggest uh
bilateral donors and particularly
um to uh Syria uh I think that it will
some be something that would have to be
looked at in the round
um as and when requests are coming for
that assistance
you know I'm going to ask you about the
foreign aid budget should be 0.7 of UK
GDP that's certainly uh what it was
under David Cameron's regime he
introduced it it continued we have
reduced that to 0.5 percent
um do you have any idea what impact that
could have on people like these young
sorry sorry these youngsters around me
if there was more financial aid coming
from the sixth most financially
structural power like the United Kingdom
well the UK of course uh shapes her very
favorably when it comes to our Aid
budget overall and obviously we have the
commitment to restore the aid budget as
soon as we're able the fiscal position
here in the UK allows us there's been no
reduction to Aid to the region we remain
one of the biggest bilateral donors in
particular to Syria the awful situation
that's been going on there obviously in
advance of the earthquake but this is
something the UK will be restoring on
the aid budget to get back to 0.7 but as
I said we do shape up very favorably
internationally in terms of the amount
of Aid that we are given
okay and when will we go back to not
point seven percent
well when the UK fiscal position allows
that uh as you'll know okay we've
difficult fiscal position uh here in the
UK we're getting to grips uh one of
Rishi suna's key priorities is to reduce
the debt uh halve inflation get that
position under control uh so that our
public finances can approve and allow us
to do that in due course
really beautiful
this year
well look uh I'll be would be right for
me to speculate on the future fiscal
position I know that the action that
we're taking we've got a budget coming
up next month but you'll have seen in uh
rishi's key five priorities laid out
last month the importance of the fiscal
position you know three of his five
priorities are reducing debt halving
inflation uh restoring growth there's
all a connection between those to
improve the UK's fiscal position to
allow us uh to spend more on the
people's priorities going forward
yeah we say that but as I said we're the
sixth richest nation in the world I'm
just going to move out the way you can
see this tented City behind me Nathan
can show you in a bit more detail these
people are sleeping in ice and snow in
Sub-Zero temperatures they've absolutely
lost everything that they had they run
out in their bare feet some of them some
of them from Syria and this is where
they're living they're relying on
countries like us we said that we would
give 0.7 of our GDP and we're not well
the UK as a CK is one of the biggest
bilateral donors the amount of money
that we give I say uh um uh shapes are
very favorably uh to International
comparators I absolutely understand the
situation there is there I know that
region well I've traveled in that region
uh before myself antakia gaziente
Aleppo these are places I know well I
and I can feel what people will be going
through at the moment but as I say the
UK our position uh is is is is very
favorable compared to many other
International countries and we are
committed to improve on that position
going forward
okay I just want to um alert you to
something quite alarming actually it's
an app it's been called a snitch app uh
it's been released by the Turkish
government and they are calling on the
Turkish people the disinformation
reporting service has been open to the
use of our people you can download and
Report the suspicious fake news produced
and spread about the earthquake disaster
to your phone
um what would you say to the Turkish
government when they issue stuff like
this
well look I haven't seen the the details
of that app
um
well I'm not really able to comment on a
on a Turkish app uh here live on your
program what I will say is the UK is
watching the situation with the
earthquake the humanitarian disaster
that is unfolding that is why we've
responded to requests from the Turkish
government to provide the assistance
that we have provided and we stand ready
to provide more
yeah but this could put Aid agency
workers and journalists working on the
grounds are illustrating what's
happening here at risk surely you must
condemn something like this well look I
think we'd have to have a look at the
details I haven't seen or heard about
this app I'm sure uh our Embassy in
Anchorage way to Mr hands forgive me for
interrupting you let me put it this way
sorry sorry we're almost out of time
will the British government look at this
uh well look I think the foreign
Commonwealth office I'm sure will study
these reports uh we've got a very good
presence on the ground uh in our Embassy
in Ankara and I'm sure this is something
uh that will come to their attention uh
but in terms of responding to the
humanitarian disaster as I say the UK
has been responding uh we stand ready to
respond further as and when we get those
requests come in from the authorities
and from the Turkish government
Before I Let You Go uh congratulations
again on your new job surprise election
Victory coming from you do you think
well I think we're building uh towards a
general election next year we've
obviously got difficult local elections
this year uh the conservative party is
overall in good shape membership is
improving uh the financial position of
the party I think is improving uh I'm
definitely up for it I know Richie sunac
is up for it we're really looking
forward to taking on uh Sakia stalma's
unreformed labor party and the other
parties as well I think the conservative
party will have a really good story to
tell at next year's general election and
we're definitely looking forward to it
okay thank you and we've managed to
bring thank you very much indeed managed
to bring him a bit of Light Relief to
some of these little people today and
they all wanted to be um on the Telly so
given that we're going into a break
let's um let's just show some of them um
who want to see how television is made
uh this morning we are at this Camp uh
throughout the day today and we will be
back in just a moment
hello again uh from alpha to the
southeast of turkey it very badly hit by
the earthquake on Monday morning
measuring 7.8 on the Richter Scale we're
at a tented City in the car park of this
Museum chatting to more of the people
that have fled here um they've no idea
how long they're going to be here for
we'll be chatting two more of them
shortly but first let's bring in um Alex
Crawford who is further to the south of
me Alex uh good morning too what are the
conditions like where you are
well I'm in antakia which is the capital
of hatai Province and this is an
entirely different picture to the one
that we saw 12 14 hours earlier if you
remember then the people were coming up
to us everywhere we went residents were
coming up complaining about how they
were not getting any Aid they were not
getting any support they didn't have any
big mechanical diggers or any big
machinery to try and help them in their
relief effort to try and find relatives
who they believe are still trapped
underneath the rubble and alive this
morning at Daybreak there were lines of
heavy machinery on the entrance to
antakir and and hatai and here just in
one of the main areas there's lots of
residential blocks around here as well
as businesses it is a wash with people
there are volunteers there are Medical
Aid teams there are emergency rescue
teams there are military police there is
well dozens of mechanical diggers and
excavation equipment all around here and
they are furiously going at all the
collapsed buildings and there are very
very many of them the scene is one of
utter Devastation here it's one of the
hardest if not the hardest hit area in
the whole of turkey and we're talking in
comparative terms where every area is so
badly hit and you can see they are there
are now scores and scores and scores of
people taking part in this search and
rescue effort they're spending a lot of
time clearing a lot of the debris away
there's a great deal of tension in the
area because many of the residents are
extremely angry that it's taken so long
to get a substantial coordinated or
semi-coordinated effort help relief
effort here to this area and so far
unfortunately all we have seen is them
retrieving corpses we he saw a line of
them I would say maybe half a dozen body
bags and other bodies put under blankets
which are laid out in a clearing
some of them have got labels on them
and relatives are sort of coming up and
checking the label every now and again
and one man who saw and recognized the
label just utterly crumpled in front of
it and is now sitting just next to this
this body bag crying I'm refusing to
leave it is a really heart-wrenching
scene have a look at this okay and all
your viewers is that another building
every building around here is maybe not
entirely toppled like uh this one it's
just pretty destroyed that that Jake's
focusing on right now but right next to
it is another residential area and you
can see the the trail of tied together
sheets as people have tried to scramble
out presumably when the first Quake hit
now they believe many relatives we've
seen sort of gathering around here they
believe there are still their loved ones
inside there and they keep on telling us
that they're hearing sounds and that's
why they're there's still this certain
amount of desperation another
um just a vision that I want to show you
is look look at all these these rescue
workers here now they were just not here
12 14 hours ago when we were last here
so they have really poured a great deal
of effort into this and we've heard
residents complaining that they've had
to to shout and scream and stamp to get
attention for this area one one woman
saying why did we have to cry why did we
because the the social media platforms
were Awash with please when we were here
earlier they were yesterday they were
coming up to us complaining saying we
need help we need help we need help we
saw a volunteer truck they driven a van
full of donations food donations
clothing donations and they were handing
it out to a crowd who were utterly
desperate hands reaching out grabbing
the things fights breaking out as they
were scrapping over warm clothing
mothers crying saying I need this I've
got children I need this more than you
it really is a desperate situation here
and even though it has ramped up
substantially since uh 12 hours earlier
there's no question that this is going
to be a long game a long haul and they
need so there isn't enough people that
they could send here right now there
isn't enough mechanical equipment that
they could send here right now because
the the area is so badly impacted and of
course the government the authorities
are dealing with it on a such a big
scale with at least 10 cities massive
cities and areas affected and a very
large wide earthquake zone which has
been impacted by these multiple
earthquakes
okay Alex just before I let you go this
snitch app that you um pointed me
towards this morning asked the
government Minister about it he says
that uh Brit's on the ground uh
um government officials on the ground
will be looking into it what's it all
about
well I think this is indicative of a
number of things we are dealing with
um a government an authority which is
very suspicious of particularly foreign
reporters and very doubtful of getting a
fair Shake of of the stick if you like
as far as coverage in this area so they
start from that point of view that if
you're a foreign journalist and you're
coming to Turkey you're not patriotic
like uh fellow Turkish journalists
you're not going to be on Turkey side so
they start from that point of view
secondly this is an election year with
President erdogan probably taking part
in what is likely to be a very close
contest and he's mindful of that he's
under serious economic pressures because
not only of the global economic meltdown
as a result of covet and other things
but also because
his largely questionable economic
policies and there's been soaring
inflation it was nearly 100 percent
around December it's now dropped down to
about 60 but that has had a big impact
on people's livelihoods and they were
very
um quick Off the Mark yesterday to just
to pour water on our claims that they
hadn't responded adequately or well
enough or quickly enough in certain
areas particularly here in hatai and
very very early on there were this is
all fake news when when they were
presented with claims that they hadn't
responded quickly enough particularly in
this area I mean turkey has got a huge
Army a huge Defense Forces which it
deploys regularly around the world and
yet we don't see any soldiers around
here we've seen military police but no
soldiers and as I say yesterday there
was literally no Aid workers of any
description certainly no government
coordinated response now they will say
that they're dealing with a massive
scale you know a disaster on a massive
scale but I suspect the attempt to try
they've set up this WhatsApp group this
phone line This sort of communication
system basically urging
um people to snitch on those journalists
or anyone who's spreading what they deem
to be fake information or disinformation
and they're very sensitive extremely
overly sensitive about anything which
appears to be critical of how the
government is is organizing anything in
particular a massive tragedy like this
one
okay Alex thanks very much indeed for
the update
um back to Alex we've got a special
program actually coming up for you here
on Sky News later in the day Alex of
course an integral part of that meantime
let sir take you to uh speak to a couple
of other people that we found in this uh
tented City 1500 people are presently
staying here it's in the car park of a
museum here in our film uh 25 uh people
per tent
um I think we are going to be able to
speak to Mohammed who is here
and this is this is Allied actually Ali
can speak to us
translated by um our producer Zane um
how did he get here who's living here
um
[Music]
Ali is very commonly allowed us to come
inside the 10th and Zane will come as
well go through if you would please
um where did they come from
each other
foreign
[Music]
in an old house when they felt the
Tremors they all left and he was
thankful to the Turkish government for
providing support to him and families
like him and allowing him to come to a
place like this and how long and finally
do they expect to be here
[Music]
we'll have it we'll have to leave it to
God to decide we don't know how long
we'll be here but thanks very much again
the Turkish government have provided us
with help and food and support but the
only thing is it's very cold and we you
know we don't have many blankets so it's
very very cold for the families in here
okay we'll leave them to it thank you
thanks so much indeed okay let's talk to
you about some of the aid that has been
sent here should we the UK has sent um
76 a search and rescue specialist to
turkey with uh four search dogs and
rescue equipment as well as emergency
medical team
a Chinese earthquake rescue team has
arrived in Adana in Turkey made up of 82
members and four search dogs with 20
tons of supplies and equipment
and Qatar which has already sent Aid to
Turkey is offering 10 000 container
homes for people left homeless
I was chatting to Greg Hans actually who
is the new conservative chairman elected
just yesterday representing the
government on the program this morning
this is what he had to say
thing at such a
um such a challenged part of the world
uh Syria the Turkish border I mean it's
a really terrible uh situation and in
many ways a terrible place for this to
actually happen but we are responding
we'll respond to any further requests
from the Turkish government in
particular to provide assistance from
the UK I don't have though the facts of
the uh the length of time uh but we all
I know is that we have responded
directly to that request uh from the
Turkish government We Stand ready uh to
provide more assistance should further
requests come through
okay so we're wandering back um to uh
some other points that we'd like to
illustrate to you in just a second
before that let's bring in Tamara should
we he's standing by at the foreign
office for us this morning
um tomorrow
um just watch where your where you're
stepping there uh tomorrow good morning
what do you make of what the minister
had to say this morning
K what incredible scenes where you are
and here at the foreign office behind me
they are coordinating uh the British Aid
at some of which has already arrived in
the region last night it was confirmed
that the British team comprising 77
search and rescue Personnel they are
people who work in UK Fire and Rescue
Services for example four search dogs
and some equipment some specialist
equipment to seismic equipment to see if
they can listen out for anyone who might
be trapped beneath the rubble and some
specialist digging equipment all of that
arrived yesterday afternoon and I'm told
that those search teams immediately got
to work there in Turkey to try and help
with those rescue efforts in these
critical hours but of course there's big
concern about what's going on in
Northwest Syria where a lot of Aid
agencies cannot reach the UK has given
them money they've given two and a half
million pounds to the white helmets who
are helping over there and the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak told president
erdogan in a call last night that they
stand ready to give more if needed
okay Tamara thank you bringing you uh
all the latest news from here in turkey
and Syria throughout the morning of
course but first let's take a quick look
at some of the other news that's been
making headlines through the night
President Biden has called for Unity
between Republicans and Democrats to
deliver his agenda in his prime time
State of the Union Address overnight in
a wide-ranging speech he addressed a
federal abortion rights police brutality
and gun laws and delivered a sharp
warning to Beijing over the Spy balloon
shot down last week
committed to work with China where we
can advance American interest and
benefit the world but make no mistake
about it
as we made clear last week if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did
firefighters unions say their members
will strike if there is no breakthrough
in last minute talks today they're
calling for a significant shift from
employers after their members voted for
industrial action following a five
percent payoffer
it's been reported that hs2 services
will be almost halved with trains
traveling more slowly as part of
cost-cutting proposals reports in the
Daily Telegraph say ministers are
looking for savings the department for
transport has said it does not comment
on speculation
the image of the king which will feature
on first and second class stamps has
been revealed the new stamp design
features Charles head and neck and the
king is shown facing left they go on
sale from the 4th of April and the
King's request existing stamps featuring
his late mother the queen will not be
pumped but instead used up over time
back here to Turkey and hundreds of
thousands of people have had to flee
their homes following the earthquakes
both here in turkey and also across the
border in Syria Aid organizations are
rushing to help those worst affected
let's bring in Usman Ali he's an aide
coordinator for Muslim hands hello to
you Usman thank you for joining us on
the program what a 48 hours it's been
for the people both here behind me and
indeed right across this country and
into Syria what are you doing to help
uh first of all thank you for having me
uh we as a Muslim hand we already uh we
had some work in this region so at the
moment I'm in Mirage Province uh one of
the main districts uh affected by uh
this earthquake we as a Muslim hand uh
already we have volunteers and teams but
I myself I'm based in Istanbul so we
drove roughly around 22 hours over here
and we reached our night and now we as a
Muslim here we are doing the
distributions and helping the people in
need as their emergency response on the
first time
foreign
has been reported as one of the worst
hit provinces it is hope that Aid is
moving certainly in that direction what
are you hearing
actually on our way from Istanbul to
this area witnessed a lot of heavy
machines were moving from the different
provinces a lot of ambulances and
actually this is the reason in this area
by looking at the surrounding uh side
almost all of the streets have been
destroyed it is like you can see
different buildings and nobody no one is
living at in these buildings now so they
are settled in in defense and on our way
we have witnessed a heavy machinery
coming but due to the weather condition
uh there was struggle they were
struggling to reach in this city six
more than 600 buildings are demolished
perhapsed but a lot of places are still
waiting for the help so this is the
general situation actually that's why a
lot of points initially they started to
work but uh Lake of the Machinery due to
the Lake of the Machinery uh now they
are painting is still there waiting for
the Machinery to reach but this is the
situation
foreign
who do you prioritize
uh from the ground actually as emergency
response we start in our work
benefits even now luckily the weather is
clear today but uh for last one week
there was a raining I was so cold and
that's why we have started to distribute
the winter kids and this is what we're
still doing even in this area we brought
uh the hot wing and the winter things in
this area but there's a huge piece as
Muslim hand we initially started work
with the 100 000 pounds and this is
at the moment and we would like to thank
our donors for this sport but there's a
huge line if we are reaching to one
point in a five to ten minutes there is
like hundreds of pupils in the queue
okay okay thank you so much for taking
the time to join us thank you let's
bring in someone who knows about
structural damage when it comes to
earthquakes Professor tiziana Rosetta
um joining us from London hello to you
thank you for joining us Professor on
the program this morning how surprised
are you about the impact that this
earthquake has had on this region
um I'm not surprised at all I mean we
keep talking about it as one earthquake
these are actually two massive
earthquakes that have happened in Rapid
succession
um which you know no one can design or
these are and I can't stress how large
these events are and the fact that
they've happened so close together
hitting the same area damaging buildings
under the first 7.8 magnitude events
um and then maybe the 7.5 magnitude
earthquake that follows collapsing the
buildings
um and in turkey has a very strong
seismic building code which uh the most
modern versions come in in 2018 not all
buildings are are built to withstand
earthquakes like the modern ones should
be but even the modern ones would not be
designed for such large events happening
and you know two of them in Rapid
succession and the massive aftershocks
that have also happening
we can't predict earthquakes can we but
given that we're the 7.8 happened and
then the 7.5 I think happened you know
within uh just a few hours afterwards is
there any way that we could have
expected that to happen or is it just
that we were expecting aftershocks
um no we were expecting aftershocks uh
here we have two distinct faults the
first earthquake happened uh closer to
the Dead Sea
um on a fault but then the ground
shaking from that 7.8 magnitude trigger
of the second earthquake um that is a
7.5 on the East Anatolia Vault
um so I you know these
these folds are complex and the
seismicity of the areas complex we know
that there was a seismic Gap there
we would expect a pattern but not to
such large events happening rapid
succession
what do we know about this Anatolian
fault that runs uh through the heart of
Turkey
um part of it just 20 kilometers away
from Istanbul the most populated city in
the country
um so that's the north Anatolia fault
which is different again
um
it has a large number of bolts that
happen
um it also has an extremely uh modern
and uh and vast network of measuring
instruments so for measuring and
monitoring earthquakes and it has a
strong earthquake engineering community
and seismic codes
um however events like this I I just
sort of Fairly unpredictable and and
this has affected so many people I can
expect the number of buildings that have
collapsed to do as we start to see more
and more information to go up
okay thank you Professor thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
um the death toll here in uh turkey and
in The Wider region heading into Syria
we're told has reached up to 9 000
people those are the latest figures that
we are receiving that earthquake the
initial earthquake 7.8 on the Richter
Scale in the early hours of the morning
when many people were still asleep no
chance whatsoever to get out from under
those crumbling buildings continuing
coverage on Sky
foreign